voilà merci beaucoup
mes chers collègues nous avons le
plaisir ce matin de recevoir Madame
Véronique Bedag directrice générale du
groupe Nexity dans le cadre d'une
audition qui fait l'objet d'une
captation vidéo diffusée en direct sur
le site internet du Sénat madame la
Présidente sans doute n'est-il pas
inutile monsieur Duplomb voilà madame la
inutile pour ceux d'entre nous qui ne
vous connaissent pas déjà de dire
quelques mots de votre parcours si riche
qui est marqué depuis le début à la fois
pour par une appétence pour le monde
économique et par un attrait pour le
service public côté économie vous êtes
dans une ancienne élève de l'ESSEC avait
été en poste à la direction du budget au
FMI et depuis 2017 vous exercez des
responsabilités imminentes au sein du
groupe Nexity jusqu'à prendre à la suite
d'Alain Dina comme directrice générale
présidente directrice générale depuis
quelques jours donc félicitations côté
service public vous êtes une ancienne
élève de Elena vous avez été secrétaire
général de la Ville de Paris puis
directrice du cabinet du premier
ministre Manuel Valls malgré vos
responsabilités au sein d'une excitive
vous continuez d'être engagés puisqu'en
2017 vous avez qu'au président le comité
action publique 2022 sur la réforme de
l'État en 2021 vous avez participé à la
Commission pour la relance de la
construction de logements présidée par
François Rebsamen en fin depuis quelques
semaines vous avez accepté d'animer avec
christophe Robert le directeur général
de la Fondation Abbé Pierre le volet
logement du Conseil national de la
refondation c'est dire madame la
Présidente si vous êtes vraiment
extrêmement qualifiée pour partager avec
nous ce matin votre vision de la
politique du logement de la ville de
demain et du rôle des différents acteurs
privés tels que Nexity mais aussi public
l'État et les collectivités
territoriales dans votre fine fil
LinkedIn j'ai relevé la synthèse que
vous faites de votre interview la
semaine passée sur France Info et qui me
semble bien résumé la situation je vous
cite je suis toujours frappée par le
même constat le logement crée un débat
passionné il intéresse les médias parce
qu'il est au cœur de la vie des
concitoyens et il reste pourtant le pas
en pauvre des politiques publiques nous
dites-vous il faut que la crise soit
installée que les Français n'arrivent
plus à se loger et à payer leur facture
d'énergie pour que l'État bouge et
agissent dans leurs dans l'urgence j'en
appelle donc à l'état stratège et
planificateur alors que nous sommes bien
loin alors que nous sommes bien dans
cette crise du logement et cette
transition écologique douloureuse que
vous évoquez avec des volets
énergétiques et écologiques des tensions
sur les matières premières des défis
sociaux en termes de pouvoir d'achat et
de capacité à se loger en particulier
dans les zones tendues et des dynamiques
de marché post covid-19 qui rebattent
les cartes nous comptons sur vous
aujourd'hui pour entrer dans cette
réflexion stratégique progresser dans la
construction d'un corps large entre les
acteurs et approfondir le rôle de chacun
madame la Présidente je vous passe la
parole pour avoir votre vision globale
sur à la fois cette crise mais aussi le
marché que vous connaissez bien et que
vous abordez aujourd'hui du côté du
secteur privé et ensuite Dominique
Estrosi ça sonne interviendra vous
posera les premières questions
puisqu'elle est notre rapporteur au
budget sur la mission logement et je ne
doute pas que les autres sénateurs
auront envie de vous interroger ensuite
Madame la Directrice
je propose de faire une petite
introduction parce que je pense qu'il
vous intéresse c'est plutôt qu'on
échange au fond alors évidemment vous
l'avez souligné j'ai un parcours au fond
qui me donne qui peut me donner si
simultanément plusieurs regards le fait
d'avoir travaillé à l'État au sein d'une
collectivité et puis dans une entreprise
publique donne un regard sans doute plus
large mais si vous le permettez ce matin
je vais m'exprimer comme présidente
directrice générale de Nexity
comme praticienne au fond du logement je
pense que déjà c'est beaucoup
et puis je pense que c'est aussi
intéressant dans des politiques
publiques d'avoir au fond le regard d'un
praticien de quelqu'un qui tous les
jours se préoccupe au fond du lot de
construire du logement alors vous
compreniez un peu le regard que je peux
avoir Nexity ça fait plusieurs métiers
nous on dit qu'on souhaite on va vers un
positionnement de d'opérateur global de
l'immobilier c'est parce qu'on a sur le
marché de l'immobilier au fond une
structure très spécifique
je pense qu'on y reviendra parce que
j'imagine qu'on parlera de zanes à un
moment donné mais notre premier
j'imagine notre premier métier
historique c'est un métier d'aménageur
un métier d'aménageur on sait toujours
soucier de ce qui était déjà là on est
ISO 4000 ans depuis depuis 2004 c'est
voilà donc on s'est vraiment toujours
préoccupé d'intervenir de prendre en
considération ce qui était déjà là quand
on est intervenait on fait évidemment de
l'aménagement urbain on est promoteur
c'est probablement sous ce sous cette
image là que vous m'attendez d'une
certaine façon on crée à peu près 20 000
logements par an donc l'année dernière
on a lancé des chantiers pour 20000
logements
mais ce promoteur là il a déjà beaucoup
changé moi quand je dis 20000 logements
je dis 20000 logements neufs c'est un
peu plus complexe que ça c'est 20000
logements neufs ou rénovés
pour vous donner des exemples
l'année dernière pendant un mois et demi
je me suis déplacée on m'envoie inauguré
120 logements à au Havre et je découvre
dans la semaine qui précède que en
réalité ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on a
rénové la caserne de pompiers la fameuse
caserne de pompiers qui n'a pas été
détruite pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale et en fait les 120 logements ou
les crée dans la caserne de pompiers
pour mes équipes on le vend comme du
logement neuf c'est du logement neuf et
puis après je pars à Montpellier caserne
d'infanterie au cœur de Montpellier moi
et et je marche au fond dans dans notre
chantier je me dis mais en fait moitié
neuf moitié rénovée donc vraiment
aujourd'hui dans nos métiers les choses
changent nous nous sommes des grands
transformateurs je vais vous faire
sourire de parking silo en logement
moi je suis une grande adepte des
parkings silos je trouve que dans ces
périodes intermédiaires plutôt que de
construire en sous-sol très cher pour
des pour des parkings dont on n'est pas
toujours sûr de l'avenir au fond des
parkings silos à un moment donné ça se
transforme c'est idiot ça paraît très
très facilement en logement on
transforme aussi des bureaux en logement
moi je suis extrêmement prudente sur ces
sujets là j'ai toujours un mes équipes
ne produisez pas de logement dans lequel
vous ne voudriez pas que vous enfonce
installent une ligne rouge assez simple
le bon sens quelquefois au fond quand
j'ai un douche des enfants tu es sûr et
enfin quand ils ont pas très sûr moi je
suis sûr que c'est pas un bon projet
et l'expérience que l'on a de ces
produits là c'est que vraiment on les
sort bien quand on sort dans un mix de
projet c'est à dire que quand vous
transformez du bureau vous transformez
du bureau en logement en commerce en
bureau faut faire du mixte en réalité
donc vraiment nous on s'est lancé sur
ces sujets là de façon assez naturelle
non mais moi j'ai une j'ai au fond une
filiale qui s'est spécialisée là-dedans
mais tout le monde sur le territoire
désormais travaillent avec ce qui est
déjà là
autre point intéressant et je pense
qu'en 2026 pour vous donner un ordre de
grandeur je pense qu'à peu près 10% de
la production sera au fond de d'une des
choses que j'aurais travaillé à partir
de bâtiments existants à peu près 10%
2026 donc ça va quand même très vite
deuxième regard que je peux avoir sur
les choses nous sommes également
prestataires de services alors ça c'est
très rare en France vous avez soit des
promoteurs soit des gens qui font du
service je me compare soit Altarea ou
Kaufman soit Foncia ou à Citya par
exemple moi je fais les deux métiers
donc je fais du syndic
métier complexe mais métier extrêmement
intéressant pour connaître la réalité de
ce qui se passe dans le logement
existant pour nous c'est un métier
auquel on tient beaucoup évidemment je
fais de la transaction et je fais de la
location et puis historiquement on est
rentré dans des métiers d'exploitation
donc on a un moment donné était
majoritaire dans Egide de métisse qui
fait des résidences pour personnes âgées
on est désormais minoritaires mais on a
toujours
une part au capital on fait des
résidences étudiantes studiants
très intéressant également on fait du
coliving on est vraiment rentré dans
toutes ces activités d'exploitation qui
sont au fond de plus en plus demandés
par nos clients
donc mon regard en fait il est vraiment
il passe très souplement du 9
rénové à l'existant et je pense que dans
le moment où vous voyez bien que le
regard de tout le monde se déplace de ce
flux de logements neuf qui à peu près là
je vais vous donner un ordre de grandeur
375 000 logements neufs par an un stock
de logements qui a 36 millions ça change
complètement le regard qu'on porte sur
sur le marché du logement
nous avons des engagements très forts
les engagements historiques c'est la
ville inclusive ça c'était l'engagement
historique d'Alain Dinard un tiers de
notre production c'est du logement
social
on a également une activité non profite
qui qui est de la pension de famille
on propose Homère c'est toujours une
discussion avec la mère on propose Homer
lorsqu'ils le souhaitent aux endroits où
ils le souhaitent parce que souvent ils
le souhaitent mais vraiment c'est
l'endroit qui est très travaillé avec
eux des pensions de famille qu'on
construit en homme profite on ne fait
pas de marge on a des accords depuis le
début c'était Emmanuel Coste qui nous
avait aidé à monter ses grands accords
on a des accords avec des grands
opérateurs et moi quand je dis un mère
je suis prête à faire une pension de
famille je peux le faire j'ai le terrain
et tout de suite j'ai de l'exploitant et
ce alors quelquefois le maire me dit non
non il y en a que je veux pas je veux
pas un grand je veux quelqu'un de local
moi tout me va l'essentiel c'est que je
suis soit sûre que la pension de famille
est vraiment exploitée
donc ça en 2026 on aura créé 1000
logements comme ça alors ça paraît peu
mais c'est quand même par rapport à ce
que vous connaissez des chiffres des
personnes qui sont à la rue mais c'est
la contribution de Nexity en tout cas
au logement pour tous et puis on a une
fondation qui est extrêmement tactile et
qui au fur et à mesure parce que nous
sommes une entreprise très pragmatique
c'est tournée de plus en plus vers les
jeunes
quelques exemples parce que c'est un peu
c'est un peu l'histoire de l'entreprise
qui se construit comme ça moi je quand
je suis arrivé chez Nexity je me suis
engagée sur les stages de 3e parce que
j'avais le souvenir à la mairie de Paris
on voyait arriver c'était terrifiant je
crois que je me suis un peu qui ont été
les stages mais au mois de janvier on
voyait arriver des candidatures on
prenait tout le monde honnêtement on
n'avait pas les moyens managériaux de ça
mais il fallait bien que ces enfants
aient des stages et donc j'ai décidé
d'ouvrir l'entreprise au stage de 3e
Nexity quand les stages de troisième
sont là c'est une autre entreprise ça
dure qu'un jour trois semaines c'est
extrêmement intéressant nous sommes ce
côté de partout mais du coup mais c'est
vraiment vous même physiquement vous
rentrez dans l'entreprise vous savez
qu'il se passe quelque chose et puis ben
c'est jeunes se sont intéressés à nous
ils nous ont dit mais c'est bien est-ce
qu'on peut aller voir vos chantiers donc
on a emmené beaucoup de jeunes voir nos
chantiers et puis après ils me sont dit
mais enfin quand même on voudrait bien
être formé ce que vous pouvez nous
former alors là moi j'étais pas du tout
enfin d'une entreprise bah finalement on
a répondu à leur demande nous on a créé
deux CFA
on forme à peu près 80 jeunes parents
dans les dans nos métiers alors c'est
peu mais on est une entreprise c'est
peu et c'est beaucoup parce qu'après
nous on les recrute évidemment il suffit
pas de les former et leur dire bah
écoutez aller chercher du travail donc
on les recrute donc vraiment on crée un
lien et ça intéresse beaucoup les
collectivités aussi forcément et nos
stages de 3e je dois le dire ce sont des
stagiaires qui ne sont pas les enfants
de nos collaborateurs ce sont vraiment
les les stagiaires que nous envoient les
villes avec lesquelles on travaille
deuxième engagement ça c'est peut-être
que moi j'ai mon addition même si
c'était déjà dans les jeunes de Nexity
mais sur lequel j'ai vraiment mis le
poids du corps qui est vraiment le
développement durable moi j'ai toujours
pensé que pour une entreprise comme
lexity c'était pas c'était pas une
contrainte c'était pas quelque chose
qu'on nous imposait c'était le chemin
qu'il fallait qu'on prenne et que ça
nous donnerait un avantage comparatif
sur le marché je pense que c'est le cas
aujourd'hui nous sommes le premier
promoteur ba carbone de France et nous
qui en produisons le plus et nous sommes
allés jusque à l'assemblée générale de
l'année donc de l'année dernière nous
engager sur une une trajectoire sur
lequel je fais tous les ans 10% de mieux
que la R20
ce que nous les revend pas on fait quand
à la quand elle est sortie au débat nous
on l'a prise tout de suite on sait pas
dit on va se battre contre voilà on
s'est dit au moins on sait ce qu'on doit
faire c'est quand même un vrai avantage
dans une industrie plutôt que moi je
vois la différence avec la biodiversité
très complète sous grosso modo il y a
pas encore de chemin l'avantage de
l'aéron 20 c'est que vous connaissez le
chemin donc on l'a vraiment prise
et je pense que ça me donne vraiment un
avantage comparatif sur le marché on
[Musique]
ose on innove c'est pas toujours facile
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser
parce que voilà parce que la
réglementation enfin je vous passe tous
les détails mais en tout cas nous sommes
nous sommes en train de construire à
Lyon à Confluence un immeuble sans
chauffage et sans climatisation un
immeuble de logement sans chauffage et
sans climatisation
on a obtenu un permis d'innover mais
pour vous faire sourire quand même la
réglementation française n'autorise pas
en aucun cas qu'on puisse construire des
logements sans chauffage et donc il a
quand même fallu à la fin que nous
mettions un petit truc de chauffage dans
l'immeuble qui évidemment
voilà c'est la réalité c'est pas grave
moi je mets mes équipes me disent enfin
Véronique du coup
enfin c'est un bâtiment sur lequel je
dépense plus d'argent mais c'est ma
courbe d'apprentissage c'est pas le
rythme de croisière dit mais en plus si
on met du chauffage mais ça sert à rien
ce que je dis c'est pas grave on va pas
gagner d'argent là-dessus mais il faut
qu'on y a il faut qu'on apprenne il faut
qu'on montre que ça fonctionne sans
chauffage et puis c'est tout on va y
arriver on va faire quand même juste ça
c'est un petit peu une petite expérience
d'entreprise faut dire que quelquefois
et vraiment tout le monde était prêt à
nous aider les locaux étaient super
soutenants le préfet très aidant mais un
moment la loi et la loi donc on peut pas
on peut pas la placer
donc voilà on a on a évidemment une
attention aussi particulière sur la
biodiversité de mon expérience la
biodiversité c'est en fait d'une très
grande complexité c'est un enfer pavé de
bonnes intentions
et du coup on tente de le prendre de
façon très pragmatique quand on
intervient dans un milieu on est d'abord
très attentif à ce qui est juste déjà là
déjà si vous êtes très attentif ce qui
est déjà là les humains d'abord quand
même très important mais aussi le milieu
naturel et vous acceptez de travailler
avec ce qui est déjà là que vous avez
compris je pense que déjà il y a de
grands progrès qui peuvent intervenir
sans même que la réglementation se
déploie
dernier point évidemment très important
pour nous c'est la au fond c'est la
performance de mon entreprise ce sont
les collaborateurs des collaborateurs de
Nexity sont tous actionnaires de
l'entreprise très important comme
alignement
et puis nous sommes Great Place to Work
c'est pas si simple que ça pour une
entreprise de 8200 personnes
mais je pense que notre chance c'est que
nous sommes une entreprise extrêmement
décentralisée alors ça des avantages et
des inconvénients quelquefois quand vous
êtes au centre moi j'ai 60 patrons sur
le territoire
ils sont mandataires sociaux ils ont des
projets et donc et bien il y a cette on
a cette vraie capacité
à faire que l'innovation et au fond
l'initiative des jeunes qui nous
entourent soit possible je vais vous
donner un exemple pour vous montrer de
quoi je parle exactement
je vais voir un projet à Lyon
et le chef de chantier me dit Véronique
il y a beaucoup de moi dans ce chantier
là
donc alors c'est le métier de promoteur
qui est le nôtre c'était une vieille
maison de de Lyon en ruine
donc on a détruit cette maison
mais il a fait deux choses que je trouve
absolument
intéressantes et c'était son initiative
la première chose qu'il a faite c'est un
trekker c'est un homme qui aime marcher
voilà et donc il a pas touché au jardin
le jardin historique est resté ce qu'il
est alors c'est pas un truc super propre
avec des avec des allées des trucs le
jardin est resté ce qu'il est il a créé
un trek qui trek dans le jardin
historique c'est je peux pas vous dire
c'est c'est merveilleux c'est c'est
vivant c'est voilà et puis il s'était
aussi un photographe il avait pris de
très belles photos de par exemple de
l'escalier de la maison qui était
magnifique de la glycine qui tombait de
la maison qui était magnifique il a
proposé à nos clients de choisir une
grande photo pour chacune des cages
d'escalier et donc il y a c'était
intéressant parce qu'il y a eu un
d'abord il y a le respect du lieu
l'histoire du lieu qui est là et puis
les futurs copropriétaires ont travaillé
à choisir l'image qui correspondait le
mieux à ce qu'il voulait et du coup
quand on se promène dans cette dans ce
projet là il y a quelque chose qui est
là et qui n'est pas ailleurs et nous
notre structure autorise tous nos
collaborateurs on parle beaucoup des
jeunes mais enfin je vous rassure tout
de suite ça touche tous les âges
à intervenir ils nous font des
propositions après on peut être d'accord
pas d'accord et ça je pense que ça joue
beaucoup dans notre attractivité
et puis dans la liberté qui peut y avoir
dans certains projets de Nexity sur le
territoire donc voilà pour qui on est
donc on est sur tout le territoire
métropolitain on est 8200 personnes je
vous l'ai dit il y a 200 agences Nexity
dans les villes moi j'y tire beaucoup
comme on y s'indique on fait de la
transaction
donc métropole ville moyenne et ça il
s'agitient beaucoup c'est quelque chose
que je vais renforcer parce que je tiens
à ce que tous les parties prenantes
puissent pousser la porte d'une agence
Nexity pour dire voilà il y a ça ou moi
mon rêve c'est qu'un jour un maire passe
une la porte d'une agence d'excitée en
disant il y a un truc qui ne va pas mais
je sais où je vais les mettre n'ont pas
forcément cette réaction là ils pensent
que c'est syndic mais en fait c'est nous
et donc moi je pense que c'est très
important aussi qu'une entreprise comme
nixity est pignon sur rue une boutique
ouverte on rentre une agence et qu'on
contribue au fond à l'animation à
l'animation des villes
que vous dire d'autre sur nous nos
clients c'est 50 % des particuliers 50%
des institutionnels
institutionnels ça peut être évidemment
la Caisse des Dépôts tout le groupe
d'actions logements tous les bailleurs
sociaux locaux et puis aussi on a vu
revenir
même extrêmement prudemment ces
dernières années très prudemment les
assureurs
qui seraient intéressent à l'idée de
pouvoir acheter du logement et le louer
donc voilà un petit peu
pardon j'étais un petit peu longue mais
pour vous dire un peu mon regard au fond
d'aujourd'hui c'est le regard que j'ai à
partir de ces métiers là à partir de ce
que je vois de ces métiers là
peut-être pour lancer le débat moi ce
que je dis les choses très simplement
moi ce que je vois aujourd'hui au fond
c'est que vous savez on a depuis un
moment un problème d'offre
ce problème d'offre c'est au fond
alors Françoise disait il faut
réhabiliter l'acte de construire je sais
pas comment il faut dire les choses mais
il y a quand même une vraie rétice alors
on parle des mères mais avant de parler
des mères il y a une vraie réticence de
nos concitoyens à la vidange faut quand
même qu'on se dise les choses soit on
rend cette ville danse désirable soit
soit il passera rien enfin c'est le cœur
du sujet est quand même là donc
effectivement on a eu beaucoup moins de
permis il y a eu il y a aussi beaucoup
de renouvellements aux dernières
élections municipales et vous savez le
temps qu'il faut pour monter des projets
donc les permis ont repris un peu
l'année dernière mais clairement on a
moins de permis qu'on en a eu et puis
est arrivé évidemment le problème de
l'offre
le problème de l'offre c'est évidemment
ne serait-ce que la montée des taux
d'intérêt qui suffirait en soi tout seul
à la baisse de la demande nous on a
calculé alors c'est des moyennes tout ça
donc évidemment ça se met que nos
clients ont perdu depuis à pouvoir
d'achat égal ils ont perdu 8 mètres 7 à
8 mètres carrés de pouvoir d'achat
depuis le début de l'année dernière
d'accord donc c'est quand même oui oui
mais c'est voilà c'est alors évidemment
et c'est pas fini voilà donc c'est quand
même un sujet on va se dire donc
évidemment alors il y a plein de débats
il y a de l'épargne enfin je vous passez
des détails mais enfin quand même dans
la réalité de la chose sans compter que
moi je pense que ce que ce qui joue
beaucoup aujourd'hui ou enfin on l'a
tous fait quand vous quand vous prévoyez
un achat immobilier évidemment vous avez
vous avez cette discussion intéressante
avec votre banque sur ce que ça va vous
coûter et en taux d'intérêt et en
assurance n'oubliez pas l'assurance
et puis après ben vous êtes jeune on l'a
toussait on sert on s'est avancer on dit
qu'on va s'en sortir mais objectivement
aujourd'hui
l'incertitude qui a sur la facture
énergétique moi je suis incapable de
dire à quelqu'un bah voilà ça va le
faire enfin vous voyez bien où on en est
du bouclier tarifs etc donc une forme
d'incertitude aussi qui retient les
Français il y a eu beaucoup aussi de
décisions bancaires que vous connaissez
par coeur je vais pas y revenir mais les
décisions prises par le conseil et la
stabilité financière début 22
parce qu'il y avait l'idée que vraiment
c'était un marché risqué un marché
spéculatif il fallait calmer tout ça bon
ça vraiment calmer le marché en début
d'année dernière après il y a eu la
montée des taux d'intérêt qui aurait
suffi au bonheur de tout le monde et
puis après on a eu vous connaissez
l'histoire parfaitement les taux d'usure
donc très clairement
alors moi j'ai pas les chiffres sont
tout parce que je j'ai pas les derniers
chiffres et c'est un secteur que je
connais pas bien sur les maisons
individuelles j'ai compris qu'on était à
peu près à -50 au deuxième semaine donc
c'est quand même vraiment et nous
probablement qu'au dernier qu'au dernier
trimestre dernier trimestre était très
mauvais on n'a pas du tout les chiffres
on est probablement de l'ordre de moins
un tiers d'accord
par rapport non non pardon sur le
collectif excusez-moi mais là je vous
donne ces chiffres pour donner des
ordres de grandeur il y a rien de
tamponner nulle part parce qu'il faut
que toutes les parce que les gens me
disent mais ce qu'il y a vraiment un
problème oui oui un problème quand même
on commence à rentrer dans des ordres de
grandeur où il y a un problème
donc peut-être
alors
oui ou non il est il est du devoir de
l'État parce que c'est un peu le ça
qu'on dans ce dans quoi on est est-ce
que oui ou non il appartient à l'État de
dire si de dire combien il faut de
logement et de mener une politique
mais évidemment en coordination et en
s'appuyant d'abord sur les autorités
locales moi je suis pas du tout une
centralisatrice dingue mais est-ce qu'il
appartient à l'État de dire combien il
faut de logements et de le prévoir je
pensais que ça n'était pas une question
pour être complètement honnête en fait
c'en est une non non mais s'en est une
on va dire les choses voilà
bon moi je crois pas à la main invisible
complète du marché je crois pas que la
somme des décisions individuelles avec
les avec les sujets de finance locale
que vous connaissez vont aboutir
naturellement à loger tous les Français
oui il faut ça je n'y crois pas du tout
mais il y a quand même cette question
moi je vous avoue qu'il m'arrive d'aller
au contact des autorités de l'État et
alors pas du tout Olivier Klein
évidemment qui meurt et qui va très bien
à quoi ça ressemble mais plus largement
on me dit mais enfin Véronique il y a
pas vraiment de problème de logement je
sais pas pourquoi j'arrive même pas dire
la phrase sans dire mais il y a pas
vraiment de problème de logement bon moi
je ne sais pas je suis je suis là où je
suis et moi là où je suis tout ce que je
dis quand on me dit ça mais je reçois
des tableaux Excel merveilleux on
explique on explique on est dans un pays
extraordinaire où il y a le plus c'est
le pays où il y a le par la Grèce le
plus de logements par habitant enfin je
vous passe tout ce que je vois alors
donc moi je vais revenir à ce que je
suis moi tout ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que dans mes agences j'ai
aujourd'hui deux fois moins de d'offres
à la location que je n'en avais avant le
covid
j'ai une fois et demi de plus de
demandes je parle de Nexity de mes
agences d'accord voilà ça je vois moi je
vois autre chose qui a été absolument
passionnant je vais vous faire sourire
une demi-seconde
quand je regarde avec mes équipes les
comptes là moi septembre ils me disent
Véronique sur les agences il arrive il
me dit tu dis on va voir 97 % de taux de
d'occupation honnêtement je ris je dis
non là il y a une erreur vous vous
souvenez on a tous été comme ça nos
enfants sont comme ça vous rendrez vous
rendez voilà clé de la résidence
étudiante fin mai vous économie c'est
normal et nous c'est dans notre modèle
vous économisez juin juillet-août ma
figurez-vous que cette année les
étudiants ont gardé leur logement nous
ne voulons pas rendu pour l'essentiel
d'entre eux ça dit quand même des choses
de l'anticipation moi c'est ce que je
vois voilà donc je dis que peut-être il
y a pas de problème de logement mais
enfin quand même je vois qu'il se passe
un truc dans mes agences qui se durcit
et puis je pense que c'est à peu près
tout ce que j'ai envie de vous dire en
introduction parce que je pense que ce
qui est intéressant c'est peut-être le
débat et comment vous voyez les choses
mais voilà en quelques mots au fond de
où je regarde ces choses là et moi je me
perds jamais sur mon rôle je sais ce que
je suis et ce que je vous dis c'est ce
que je vois moi dans mon quotidien
et puis peut-être mes premiers échanges
avec l'État au sens large voilà madame
le Président j'ai pas été trop longue
c'est bon pas du tout merci madame la
Présidente Directrice générale je vais
passer la parole à Dominique Estrosi ça
sonne pour les premières questions
merci beaucoup de cette présentation
déjà très intéressante alors j'aurais
trois questions à vous poser mais vous y
avez déjà sur l'une d'entre elles un
petit peu répandue le rapport Comité
d'action publique dont tu as parlé la
présidente de 2022 que vous avez qu'au
président avait fait des propositions
qui étaient particulièrement importantes
dans le domaine du logement et parmi ces
propositions il y avait celle de la
création d'un statut du bailleur privé
c'est une idée que je défends ici au
Sénat depuis de nombreuses années c'est
à dire celle de donner un cadre
juridique et fiscal pérenne à
l'investissement locatif privé en
contrepartie de la suppression des
niches fiscales donc là c'est un vrai
débat y compris avec votre fédération de
la Fédération des promoteurs
constructeurs je ne participe pas à la
Fédération des matériaux
de la profession donc se récré un régime
de droit commun unique pour les
investisseurs autorisant la déduction
des charges de propriété et d'un
amortissement ainsi que l'élargissement
du régime micro-foncier ou en sont ces
réflexions alors que l'on voit bien
aujourd'hui que le locatif privé est un
segment essentiel du parcours
résidentiel et qu'il y a de plus en plus
de déséquilibres entre propriétaires et
locataires ou encore
l'attrait pour le meublé de tourisme qui
agissent comme des repoussoirs à la
location de longue durée et qui assèche
malheureusement le marché du logement et
cela au détriment des Français deuxième
question autre élément essentiel et vous
y avez fait juste référence à l'heure du
Zéro artificialisation nette la
définition d'un objectif de construction
neuve là aussi au sein de la commission
repsamen dont j'étais membre également
avec vous nous avions abouti me
semble-t-il à des objectifs qui étaient
consensuels j'ai l'impression que pour
autant les tenants du tout rénovation et
du Zéro construction ont de nouveau pris
le dessus alors que cette commission
avait fait un travail intéressant pour
construire des consensus et surtout pour
penser à long terme vous avez déjà un
petit peu répondu quel est votre
sentiment à ce sujet et comment Nexity
peut faire face à ces difficultés de
l'acte de construire et puis dernière
question le parcours résidentiel alors
que l'État avait suivi une politique de
long terme pour aller en faveur de
l'accession à la propriété là aussi il
semble que notre pays est aujourd'hui
volontairement tourné la page puisque
derrière le rêve d'une maison à soi il y
a pourtant effectivement c'est quand
même la grande le grand souhait d'une
grande partie de nos concitoyens il y a
aussi derrière une promesse républicaine
d'ascension sociale qui est aujourd'hui
complètement cassé qui amène à un
sentiment de déclassement de nos
concitoyens alors c'est un enjeu
politique qui est beaucoup plus
important que ce qu'on peut croire et
derrière ce camoufle l'idée à la mode
que le partage où l'usage remplacerait
la propriété comment abordez-vous cette
question merci merci beaucoup il y a
beaucoup de il y a beaucoup de choses je
vais peut-être tenter de répondre
je pense qu'il y a un premier sujet très
large qui est pour qu'on construise du
logement il faut qu'il y ait soit des
particuliers soit des institutions pour
acheter parce que sinon nous on est
enfin moi j'ai pas d'acheteur je
construis pas enfin vous connaissez des
promoteurs j'ai pas d'acheteurs
d'ailleurs ce serait une un acte de
mauvaise gestion parce que je serais
très endetté et le marché me suivrait
pas donc il faut des acheteurs
on a dit on a dit un mot j'ai dit un mot
tout à l'heure et vous l'avez
de au fond de moi il y a le sujet du
primo-occident que vous connaissez bien
qui est quand même pour l'instant
s'éloigne un peu de la de la propriété
nous on voit bien que l'âge d'accession
à la propriété j'ai regardé ces
dernières années chez nous ça prend
presque un an tous les ans quand même là
on est à 37 ans mais c'est
l'augmentation de l'âge moyen
et quand même c'est l'âge moyen
quand même c'est pas illogique quand
vous regardez pardon
oui
mais
bien sûr mais c'est pas c'est pas
illogique il y a aussi le sujet des
investisseurs alors les investisseurs
qu'ils soient public ou privés
institutionnels ou
privé il faut quand même qu'ils aient de
la rentabilité quelque part
il y a quand même trois éléments
aujourd'hui de mon point de vue il y a
bon le blocage des loyers qu'on peut
entendre dans le moment il y a quand
même le fait que les collectivités
locales le seul impôt dont je vais
enfoncer une porte ouverte en courant là
mais le seul impôt qu'ils aient
aujourd'hui avec lequel il puisse
intervenir et enfin c'est tout moi j'ai
géré des finances d'une ville pendant 6
ans on voit bien que il faut équilibrer
le budget de fonctionnement il y a pas
d'autres solutions dans le moment donc
évidemment on s'étonne que la taxe
foncièrement je le regrette à titre
personnel mais enfin si tout ça est
quand même d'une certaine logique
mathématique mais enfin ça pèse quand
même sur les propriétaires fonciers et
puis n'oubliez pas aussi qu'il y a quand
même une perturbation dans le système
aujourd'hui qui est et loin de moi
l'idée de critiquer le fond du sujet
mais la loi la loi climat et résilience
et le fait que une bonne partie des
propriétaires aujourd'hui
souvent des retraités nous ceux qui sont
le plus en difficulté c'est des
retraités qui vous dites ben voilà on
vous écrit bonjour vous êtes une
passoire thermique pas beaucoup plus
délicatement que ça mais quand même et
donc si jamais votre locataire s'en va à
partir du temps ou du temps vous ne
pourrez plus louer il faudrait donc que
nous regardions avec vous dans quelles
conditions voilà
ça ça crée quand même une vraie
perturbation dans le moment dans le
marché nous on estimait
quand on la loi de quand on a été
consulté sur la climat résilience où on
pensait qu'un tiers un tiers de nos
clients
aller choisir de vendre parce que les
travaux c'est compliqué c'est long
nous le reste à charge vraiment pour nos
clients en moyenne de nouveau je parle
de moyenne mais il faut bien qu'on parle
de moyenne c'est 10000 euros
tous les retraités on peut pas dire
enfin pardon mais 10000 euros sur un
compte épargne et puis il faut qu'il
prenne finance les travaux puisque les
travaux chez nous à peu près c'est
20.000 euros mais c'est de nouveau c'est
des moyens c'est de ça dépend de la
taille de l'appartement vous avez c'est
à peu près ça et à la fin il reste à peu
près 10000 euros de reste à charge
d'accord et ça c'est en train de créer
une vraie perturbation sur aussi sur ce
marché de la propriété avec je pense on
voit monter dans la proportion des biens
mis à la vente
c'est passoir thermique parce que
vraiment des propriétaires qui se disent
d'abord la copropriété je vais jamais y
arriver je m'engage dans des frais voilà
et là je cours et puis il y en a qui
court un vrai risque d'avoir un
appartement qui ne peuvent pas relouer
le locataire vous pouvez parler c'est
comme un vrai sujet
donc il y a quand même une vraie
perturbation je sais pas si on en mesure
encore complètement les effets mais il
est quand même une vraie perturbation
sur ce marché historique de
l'investissement locatif on a un petit
peu la même chose du côté des
institutionnels pour que les
institutionnels privés alors évidemment
Action Logement la Caisse des Dépôts
font vraiment leur job mais pour que moi
je pense qu'il faut que les
institutionnels privés Action Logement
et la Caisse des Dépôts n'ont pas
vocation acheter tout ce qui se produit
donc je pense qu'il faut
intéresser les institutionnels privés
même si certains maires n'aiment pas
beaucoup parce qu'ils ont gardé un
souvenir ému de la des ventes à la
découpe mais ça ça se fait avec les
mères de nouveau mais il faut les ré
attirer sur le marché il faut regarder
aussi quelle est leur équilibre
économique faut malgré tout si c'est
plus rentable aujourd'hui d'aller mettre
votre agent sur du livret A que faire de
l'immobilier ben vous allez tous mettre
sur le livret A dans le respect du
plafond enfin voilà c'est quand même des
arbitrages donc le statut du bailleur
privé c'est moi ça me paraît une réponse
un peu de droit commun au fond à ces
sujets d'investissement immobilier
je comprends que dans les groupes de
travail du CNR le sujet relancé Olivier
Klein lui-même
a dit voilà ce serait il l'a déclaré une
interview parisien en disant moi je suis
je soutiens l'idée d'un statut du
bailleur privé je pense que si un
ministre s'exprime c'est que peut-être
il y a peut-être une ouverture ou une
discussion possible mais de nouveau il
faut quand même se ce qu'on a besoin de
logement ou pas dans ce pays ça dépend
de quoi on parle s'il y a pas besoin de
logement ben on va s'occuper d'autres
choses donc et moi je suis d'accord avec
vous il y a quand même une petite
musique
qui est une musique de tableau Excel si
je peux me permettre qui dit ben voilà
il y a assez de logement dans ce pays
concentrons-nous sur la rénovation oui
enfin vous savez tous que d'abord je
pense que le 9 ça permet quand même de
faire respirer l'ensemble du dispositif
moi je on a peut-être assez de logement
mais moi c'est juste que j'ai pas de
marcher locatif là donc il y a quand
même un sujet
et ça je pense que quand même
il faudrait que le CNR tranche cette
question
la première intervention de la chief
économiste de Bercy c'était en ouverture
du CNR c'était de dire grosso modo on a
besoin d'à peu près 250 ma mémoire
exemples 250 000 logements neufs par an
je dis 9 rénover on en produit
aujourd'hui 375000 à peu près
donc j'en déduis qu'il y a pas besoin
voilà
donc c'est quand même une question
moi je crois que les mondes sont plus
fluides je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure
en réalité nous on intervient de plus en
plus avec le déjà là et je vais vous
dire que dans mes systèmes d'information
je suis incapable de dire exactement
combien dans les logements neufs que je
produis en réalité sont des logements
qui qui sont créés dans dans ce qui
existe déjà mais en tout cas la
proportion monte avec un métier qui
change pour nous c'est un le métier de
promoteur était un métier qui n'exigeait
pas beaucoup de capitaux parce qu'en
réalité vous vous souvenez c'est le
système de la VFA vous payez au fur et à
mesure où vous vendez quand vous faites
de la rénovation vous achetez des
investisseurs institutionnels vous payez
tout de suite et c'est des gros objets
si on monte en dizaines de millions et
puis vous vendez plus tard en prenant un
risque souvent de PLU et de et de permis
donc c'est un métier qui change
complètement pour nous moi c'est un des
débats que j'ai avec le marché c'est oui
ou non est-ce que moi je peux m'endetter
pour financer ce type d'opération c'est
pas si simple c'est vraiment pas si
simple
parce que l'idée c'était que vraiment le
métier promoteur n'exigeait pas
finalement tant de capitaux que ça
sur la commission rêves ça mène moi je
pense que il y avait il y a eu beaucoup
de boulot très solide qui a été fait
je vais vous donner quelques exemples il
y a des fois il faut vraiment être
patient je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez madame la sénatrice dans ce que
François Rebsamen a eu été un peu agacé
par par le sujet des logements vacants
et donc nous avions sollicité quelques
économistes à l'époque pour démontrer
que en réalité
le taux de vacances était d'autant plus
bas qu'on était en zone dense et que
dans les zones denses le temps de la
vacance était plus réduit que les bons
mais on l'a démontré on a payé des
économistes pour nous le montrer donc
quand même donc ça c'était démontré par
la Commission hebsamen on ouvre le CNR
on me dit Véronique hier je sais plus
combien 8% de logements vacants voilà il
y a pas de 8% de logements vacants 10%
de résidence secondaire donc l'affaire
est faite on ne court aucun risque bon
donc moi je pense que le problème de
l'ensemble de ces rapports c'est qu'on
fait travailler des gens qui consacrent
beaucoup de temps à l'état est très
généreux avec les temps des autres en
vrai et puis la commission hep ça mène
il y a eu deux ou trois mesures
intéressantes qui ont été prises mais le
fondement même de la commission hepsamen
qui était vous l'avez dit une sorte de
consensus autour de la table à part deux
ou trois peut-être mais sur à peu près
le nombre de de logements et l'idée mais
c'est un peu ce que vous reprenez sur
les ânes l'idée au fond de décliner ça
territorialement par des par des au fond
presque des contrats territoriaux en
s'appuyant sur les régions ce qui me
paraît quand même pas bah tout ça est
passé à la trappe ce qui était
l'essentiel du rapport quand même au
début il y a un vrai besoin de logement
et donc on le décline territorialement
en échange enfin dans l'échange avec les
élus locaux ça c'est ça complètement
disparu cap 22 je n'en parle même pas
voilà donc j'espère évidemment que ce
qui sortira du CNR au sera plus
utile c'est toujours utile ces
moments-là parce que on a quand même
enfin ce qui me frappe toujours c'est
que le CNR où il y avait le logement
enfin c'est un monde de passionné et le
CNR on a quand même retrouvé beaucoup de
personnes autour de la table qui était
déjà là en commission sont prêts à
s'engager de nouveau pour qu'on trouve
des solutions enfin c'est quand même
merveilleux d'énergie collective donc là
évidemment il faudrait que mais moi je
pense que le sujet vraiment c'est
quand je réfléchis c'est le début de
l'histoire est-ce que oui ou non on a
besoin de logements supplémentaire au
moins pour faire tourner le stock enfin
les rénovations quand même les
rénovations en immeuble occupés c'est
pas toujours très simple c'est un
premier sujet
et puis deuxièmement est-ce que l'État
ou non une fois qu'on a dit bah est-ce
que l'État ou non un rôle est un jouet
moi je pensais c'est mon histoire moi je
pensais que l'État quand j'appelle les
tastreet je dis mais enfin l'État doit
quand même se dire
bah voilà il y a des besoins de logement
comment est-ce qu'on s'organise comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour que dans 10 ans
ces logements soient là c'est pareil
pour la rénovation quand même
l'autre jour alors je sais pas mais
l'autre jour je j'ai vu une étude alors
c'est l'Île-de-France
alors je sais plus comment ça s'appelle
cette institut d'Île-de-France qui est
vraiment travaille très très bien et sur
des choses toujours intéressantes ils
disent 46% des logements qui sont dans
le parc privé de l'Île-de-France sont à
terme thermique c'est énorme c'est
énorme
quand on réfléchit on peut intuiter ça
mais quand même c'est énorme c'est
énorme et donc moi je pense que ces
choses là doivent s'organiser et se
réfléchir quand même avez-vous ludique
très bien sur lasagne on peut dire on
peut dire quelque chose mais enfin quand
il faut quand même après en vrai mettre
enfin donner des ordres de grandeur je
pense que sur la zone on s'est rendu
compte après de l'impact qu'avait les
projets de l'État sur ce que on laissait
non mais enfin quand même c'est un sujet
[Musique]
oui c'est un sujet non mais on le
découvre après donc pourquoi pas mais
enfin je donc voilà donc moi je pense
que quand même on peut pas dire on voilà
il y a un truc magique qui va faire qu'à
la fin tout ça va s'organiser très bien
enfin j'ai lu ce que vos travaux sur
lasagne c'est vraiment ça c'est l'idée
de il y a quand même des choses
auxquelles il faut penser il y a quand
même des projets vous avez raison si
dans des petites collectivités oui
bonjour toi tu vas prendre ça parce que
ça nous arrange et que du coup le merde
ne peut plus rien faire il va vous dire
bah écoute ton équipement public je
crois mais le ailleurs quoi mais ça ça
n'existe pas tout ça donc voilà moi je
pense qu'il faut quand même je crois
que l'État doit penser ces choses là
parce que de toute façon il va finir
enfin moi j'étais alors je vais je vais
faire je vais retourner dans mon passé
mais moi j'étais à Matignon post loi
Duflot on a vraiment vu tomber les
permis de construire les constructions
ça fait un vrai effet sur tout le monde
sur l'économie sur aussi le moral des
Français enfin moi je veux bien que moi
je comprends certains me dit non mais
Véronique tout le monde n'a pas vocation
à acheter venge j'en sais rien en fait
il faut pas que les gens se mettent dans
une situation je comprends très bien il
faut pas que les gens se mettent dans
une en quelquefois on a vendu du rêve
certaines personnes se sont lourdement
endettées parce qu'ils pensaient qu'ils
allaient transmettre ils ont pas
transmis grand chose donc ça ça c'est
voilà ça ne va pas mais moi je ne vois
pas vraiment pourquoi on dirait aux
jeunes écouter nous nous on est bien
tranquille là on part à la retraite on a
acheté le truc enfin vous vous êtes
beaucoup plus détendu vous êtes dans
l'usage vous avez pas besoin d'acheter
mon fils il a 26 ans bah il aimerait
bien acheter c'est pas parce que je suis
dans immobilier c'est parce que c'est
normal en fait on a été comme ça moi je
vois pas pourquoi je dirais mes enfants
ben non en fait
préoccupez-vous de l'usage ça va le
faire très bien non enfin
très bien Viviane
oui bonjour et merci pour votre présence
ici au Sénat avec nous surtout fait
d'accord avec vous et on a besoin de
construction de logement neufs on est
voilà on sait très bien que la
rénovation des logements va prendre du
temps beaucoup d'argent aussi et il faut
un mixte entre les deux c'est évident
moi je voulais saluer le partenariat que
vous avez CDC habitat je vous conseille
de surveillance de la Caisse des dépôts
et consignations et je travaille
beaucoup sur ces questions là la
commission de surveillance vous avez
construit effectivement 22000 logements
neufs que vous avez cédé en VEFA en ACDC
habitats pour ces décis habitat mais
quand même sur dans ce partenariat aussi
la rénovation ne semble dévolu dans ce
que j'ai vu et qu'à une petite part de
votre activité le l'hébergement
d'urgence et les pensions de famille via
Nexity non profits nos profits et Adoma
est-ce que est-ce que vous en avez un
peu répondu vous essayez d'élargir cette
stratégie à toute l'offre de logement il
y a évidemment mais est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner quelques objectifs
dans ce domaine tout en n'oubliant pas
que privilégier la construction de
l'offre Chemin Neuf je suis d'accord
avec vous et qu'est-ce que vous pensez y
compris en termes économes de
rentabilité de communique du dispositif
second de vie qui pouvait être là sur la
question de la fiscalité aussi là plutôt
en tant que coanimatrice du Conseil
national de la refondation sur les
questions de logement le ministre a
introduit ce conseil national de
raffondation avait l'idée d'encadrement
des prix du foncier par ailleurs dans le
cadre de nos débats sur la commission de
sur le projet de loi de finances nous
avons abordé certains groupes la
question de la fiscalité immobilière et
notamment pour des droits de mutation
plus égalitaires avec la mise en place
d'un barème progressif ou encore au
travers d'une modification radicale de
la logique des plus-values qui favorise
aujourd'hui dans certaines territoires
la spéculation quel est votre analyse
sur ces sujets
beaucoup de sujets nouveaux sur la
caisse est un très grand partenaire
alors quand je dis ça vous je pense que
vous savez tout ça mais quand je dis ça
à l'extérieur les gens me regardent
l'avantage de la CDC c'est que ils sont
très exigeants en matière de
développement durable et sont vraiment
prêts à nous accompagner sur ces sujets
là enfin c'est moi je certains disent
dans les bailleurs oui les bailleurs
sociaux ils sont ils sont vraiment avec
nous sur ces sujets développement
durable des partenaires on peut innover
avec eux
on a des sur les partenariats qu'on
avait avec la caisse on a pris des
engagements très forts sur ce qu'on
livrait donc ça je pense que
la CDC joue un rôle très important aussi
non seulement elle achète des logements
mais en plus elle joue un rôle de
donneur d'ordre sur ces sujets là qui
est vraiment très important
quoi d'autre sur l'encadrement du prix
du foncier ça c'est un débat c'est un
débat absolument sans piternel mais
c'est un vrai débat parce que au fond
c'est bien à la fin moi aujourd'hui je
ne vois pour calmer les prix de du neuf
que un ajustement progressif des prix du
foncier parce que je vais pas vous
cacher que effectivement
les prix de construction tout le monde
dit ça va baisser enfin ça va ça baisse
pas du tout en ce moment je voilà non
mais
ça ne baisse pas
nos marges baisse et moi mon grand
regret pour faire de la rénovation j'ai
besoin de plus de capitaux voilà donc il
faut que j'aille chercher du capital et
pour ça faut que je le rémunère quand
vous prenez quand vous allez chercher du
capital sur du neuf pour des sommes
élevées sans être sans être au clair
mais vous savez très bien pourquoi à la
fois sur le temps que le PLU prendra à
être mis en oeuvre sur le temps du
permis et sur la constructibilité finale
je évidemment celui qui achète prend un
risque maximal qui doit être rémunéré
donc voilà
alors moi je suis un peu libéral sur ces
sujets là je pense que mais malgré tout
il y a quand même eu des villes alors le
problème le problème de ces sujets là
c'est que il faut que ce soit assez
global parce que si vous êtes ça dans
une ville vous avez des écarts de prix
d'une rue à une autre qui sont terribles
mais il y a aussi des villes qui nous
ont imposées alors faut que ce soit
raisonnable des prix de sortie mais ça
ça contraint immédiatement le prix du
foncier le problème de tout ça c'est que
il faut le faire de façon assez
raisonnable parce que après vous faites
des trucs qui risquent de conduire à un
immobilier de pas très grande qualité
parce que ça boucle plus
et puis il faut que ce soit quand même
concerté sur des zones assez larges
parce que sinon ça crée des inégalités
incroyables
bon et puis après si jamais la mairie
change et que le prix devient plus
maîtrisé les plus-values faites par les
personnes qui ont acheté à prix
maîtriser sont magiques donc le mais il
y a quelque chose autour de ce prix du
foncier qui est quand même la partie du
coût de construction qui a le enfin du
prix de production des logements qui a
été le plus pentu qui est
moi j'espère que le prix du foncier va
s'ajuster va baisser en même temps le
foncier devient une denrée de plus en
plus rare donc
voyez les exemples les exemples de
marché ou la demande croit et le prix
baisse c'est quand même des choses
qu'on n'a pas beaucoup vu dans les dans
l'histoire économique beaucoup de
modèles donc c'est voilà et sur la
fiscalité immobilière c'est un sujet
général nous on n'arrête pas de nous
dire voilà il y a beaucoup de dépenses
en matière immobilière les Condes du
logement montrent que effectivement il y
a des il y a des avantages fiscaux et
des dépenses mais que le prélèvement
fiscal sur l'immobilier c'est deux fois
plus important que ce que l'État
récupère à partir de la fiscalité donc
c'est un secteur hyper hyper fiscalisé
c'est normal c'est un truc qui bouge pas
donc c'est j'ai envie de dire non mais
c'est vrai c'est facile une certaine
façon mais il y a un moment il va quand
même falloir il va quand même falloir
choisir mais on voit bien d'où ça vient
il y avait l'idée que c'est une rente je
vous connaissez toute l'histoire
moi je vous avoue que je ne sais pas ce
que c'est que j'ai pas utilisé mais ça
prend peut-être un autre nom
bon on doit probablement l'utiliser
parce que nous on le fait beaucoup je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure caserne que
moi en 2026 ça va être un logement sur
10 à partir de ce qui mais c'est normal
c'est assez logique à partir de ce qui
est déjà là
nous on a changé de regard complètement
en 5 ans en 5 ans on arrivait sur moi
j'ai commencé ça quand j'étais sur le
tertiaire et puis après sur le logement
quand on arrive sur un terrain on
regarde vraiment très attentivement on
se dit pas non ça sera beaucoup moins
cher là-bas non on regarde très
attentivement ce qu'on sait faire avec
l'existant quelquefois j'ai des maires
qui me dit non mais enfin tu es
sympathique mais là vraiment moi j'ai
envie c'est mon entrée de vie je veux du
neuf je je suis enfin voilà il faut pas
être non plus dogmatique ça m'arrive ça
aussi je dis on pourrait essayer de
faire ça et puis on me dit non enfin là
je peux comprendre aussi il y a des
endroits où les mers peuvent avoir envie
d'autre chose une entrée de vie etc mais
honnêtement notre
notre réflexe aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
et quand vous intervenez en ville vous
tombez rarement sur des clairières on va
dire les choses donc nous notre réflexe
est vraiment de regarder de dire voilà
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire qu'est-ce qui
est et puis on était des parce que comme
beaucoup d'architectes il y avait des
architectes autrefois qui préférait être
dans le 9 le 9 vous permettez une
expression complète de voix aujourd'hui
on a beaucoup d'architectes qui
s'intéressent vraiment culturellement à
ce qui est déjà là comment on pourrait
le transformer on fait des choses
vraiment très bien
très bien alors je propose de prendre
les questions par par trois pour voilà
pour qu'on puisse avancer je donne la
parole à Alain Cadec à Evelyne Renaud
garabédian puis à Bernard but
merci madame la Présidente
madame la Présidente générale
actuellement le marché locatif est dans
une situation compliquée on vient de le
rappeler et vous l'avez dit vous-même à
plusieurs reprises
la loi climat est résilience vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure
entrez en vigueur donc depuis le 24 août
2022 prévoit d'interdire progressivement
la location des logements les plus
énergivores avec gel des loyers pour les
passoires thermiques
cette loi a défini un calendrier avec
d'importantes économiques juridique et
technique je vais pas revenir sur le
contenu de la loi en tous les cas elle
impose des aménagements sur tous les
logements et bâtiments du territoire
privé public en fonction du baromètre
DPE
l'objectif est de réduire les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre et d'atteindre
la neutralité carbone d'ici
2025 objectif 2030 objectif ambitieux et
partager
selon les derniers chiffres officiels
5,2 millions de résidence principale
doivent rentrer dans la catégorie
password thermique je sais pas si mes
chiffres sont bons mais c'est la priori
cela étant donné le contexte actuel
d'un côté l'accession à la propriété des
Français freinée par les difficultés
d'accès au crédit de l'autre les ménages
qui jonglent avec leur pouvoir d'achat
en baisse il est difficile aujourd'hui
pour les Français aussi bien d'acheter
que de louer ou de mettre en location
leur bien vous l'avez souligné tout à
l'heure
donc au regard des coûts importants des
travaux de rénovation énergétique même
si l'ensemble des propriétaires
immobiliers est conscients des enjeux
environnementaux
ne faudrait-il pas assouplir selon vous
les contraintes réglementaires sur les
nouvelles normes énergétiques ne
serait-ce que pour débloquer le marché
de la location
ou alors aider les propriétaires à
rénover
je tiens à rappeler par exemple qu'un
propriétaire minorité d'un bien d'un
proche n'aura pas forcément les moyens
pour financer le coût des travaux à
réaliser notamment après avoir payé les
frais de succession donc est-ce qu'il
faut assouplir ou pas la mise en oeuvre
de cette loi
Evelyne Renaud garabédian
merci même ma présidente madame la
Présidente j'aurai deux questions à vous
poser la première qui est concerne notre
statut de syndic pour faciliter
l'adoption des travaux de rénovation
énergétique le gouvernement envisage de
baisser le vote de la majorité en
matière de copropriété pour le ramener à
50 % au lieu des deux tiers bon
peut-être position qui est très louable
mais est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un risque de
cet abaissement de voir des
copropriétaires se trouvaient dans des
situations de surendettement ou être
poussé à des ventes forcées de leur bien
immobilier ma deuxième question elle
porte sur le jugement étudiant
native vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure et
l'un des premiers où est le premier
groupe de promotion
immobilière vous avez mis en place une
offre de logements qui collabore avec
une société de caution qui s'appelle
garantie pour pouvoir apporter des
cautions aux jeunes étudiants je suis
sénateur des Français d'étrangers j'ai
tous les ans on a en France qui entre
4000 5000 jeunes étudiants français qui
vivent à l'étranger qui rentrent en
France la moitié d'entre eux rencontre
des difficultés très importantes pour
trouver des logements en France et
notamment les bailleurs privés ou même
les bailleurs institutionnels refusent
de prendre la caution des parents qui
n'ont pas de revenus en France qui n'ont
pas de déclaration en France et qui ne
peuvent pas délivrer de cautions je
voulais voir avec vous s'il était
envisageable que l'on tienne un
rendez-vous avec les équipes des Nexity
studéens pour éventuellement discuter
sur une marche à suivre pour aider ces
jeunes étudiants français vivant à
l'étranger pour bénéficier de cautions
en matière de d'obtention de logement
merci merci Evelyne et Bernard buis
merci présidente madame la Présidente
Directrice générale j'ai deux questions
la première porte sur la régulation du
marché immobilier en matière de location
récemment invité dans la matinale de
français info vous avez déclaré que si
les prix de l'immobilier sont en train
de s'assagir le marché de la location
est en train de se bloquer selon vous
est-ce positif dans le cas contraire
avec une bande qui ne cesse d'augmenter
face il y a une offre qui se réduit
comment agir pour débloquer ce marché la
deuxième question porte sur la
régulation du marché immobilier en
matière de spéculation secteur complexe
à analyser le marché immobilier suscite
bien souvent des inquiétudes et des
craintes notamment en matière de
spéculation quel est votre regard sur ce
sujet en quoi le Parlement pourrait-il
intervenir pour limiter ce phénomène
voilà les trois questions
sur la loi climat et résilience
je pense qu'on est tous d'accord et vous
avez beaucoup travaillé sur la zone et
j'ai vu que vous aviez d'ailleurs écrit
que voilà c'était pas l'objectif qui qui
vous préoccupait mais la mise en œuvre
je pense que c'est pareil pour cette
histoire de passoire thermique au fond
quelque chose qui est intéressant c'est
que dans nos agences aujourd'hui
que les que nos clients viennent pour
louer ou pour acheter il y a quelque
chose qui nous demande désormais
toujours c'est quand même très
intéressant c'est le DPE
ça franchement ça n'existait pas il y a
deux ans
vous souvenez comment ça se passait des
peu arrivé en couleur à la fin vous je
tiens à un regard voilà aujourd'hui
en l'occurrence ma dernière visite c'est
à Dijon donc je rentre dans l'agence de
Dijon et moi je pose toujours des
questions ça se passe comment qu'est-ce
que vous voyez ce que vous avez des
impayés enfin toujours intéressant c'est
ça ne dit pas l'ensemble du territoire
mais c'est quand même très intéressant
donc on a deux agences et mes équipes me
disent qui changent vraiment c'est l'une
des premières questions qu'une pose nos
clients quand ils s'assoit c'est quand
même intéressant ça ce truc qui est
rentré voilà avec bon bref et donc la
première question qu'il te pose moi je
pensais que c'était vrai en à l'achat je
pensais pas que ça l'était en location
mais le problème de la facture
énergétique fait que les gens se disent
bon voilà et ben il y a ils ont ils
essuyaient donc c'était descendre il
commence à essuyer alors que franchement
le Machu de la location est vraiment
bloqué des refus de personnes disent moi
je peux pas louer ça parce que moi je
sais pas où je vais aller
en tout cas je refuse complètement
d'acheter une passoire thermique
alors que pas sur arthermique c'est un
peu moins cher
aujourd'hui il y a des codes quelque
chose entre nous nous dans nos dans nos
agences la décote aujourd'hui c'est à
peu près 6%
j'ai lu que ça pouvait aller jusqu'à
moins 15% sur une maison individuelle
aujourd'hui
donc en tout cas ce sujet il est
complètement une vraie préoccupation des
Français que ce soit à l'achat que ce
soit aussi à la location parce qu'ils
ont parce qu'il y a cette idée quand
même les Français ont très bien compris
qu'aujourd'hui c'était l'État qui
prenait en charge je sais plus combien
mais ça doit être à peu près 80% du coup
d'augmentation de l'énergie c'est ça la
réalité quand même ça pourra pas durer
quand même une éternité donc les
Français ont bien compris qu'il y avait
un sujet là non mais enfin on va quand
même se voilà
donc c'est une vraie préoccupation
moi je pense qu'il faut y aller ça ça
change complètement les métiers de de
d'entreprise comme la mienne alors nous
on est très très présent sur la
rénovation énergétique on s'en est on
s'en est préoccupé déjà il y a longtemps
mais mais honnêtement c'est
il faut avoir la foi du charbonnier on
va quand même les choses parce qu'il
faut souvent trois assemblées générales
il faut convaincre nous c'est vraiment
équipé on a des partenaires on sait
aller chercher les subventions
enfin c'est pas une rapidité quand même
puis il y a beaucoup de projets que vous
montez puis la copropriété de votre part
et puis c'est tout vous le faites pas
moi je pense que ici comme ailleurs il
faut quand même qu'on mesure les impacts
je pense que le problème de ces lois
mais j'ai trouvé le travail sur la scène
vraiment très intéressant parce que vous
montrez bien qu'en réalité on est
globalement d'accord sur l'idée qu'il
faut qu'on s'arrête mais mais quand même
enfin moi je suis d'accord voilà
j'assume l'idée qu'il faut qu'on se
résonne
mais
il faut quand même mesurer les impacts
quoi enfin il y a des territoires
entiers ou une enfin vous prenez la loi
telle qu'elle les élus ne peuvent c'est
fini voilà des équipements publics sont
elles que c'est fini c'est quand même je
sais pas ça se regarde avant quand même
donc moi je pense que c'est ça qui
manque sur ces lois là les fameuses
études d'impact quand j'étais jeune on
vous souvenez il y avait quand vous
voulez les lois c'est pas je me suis dit
que j'allais aller je ne ris pas je vais
aller chercher je pense que je suis sûr
que j'ai trouvé ça dans vos archives et
dans dans vos rapports l'étude d'impact
de sur la loi qui m'est résilience
qu'est-ce qu'on a mesuré à ce moment-là
il faut bien chercher voilà j'espère que
vous avez du temps parce que si vous
avez dit c'est intéressant
moi je me souviens moi je me souviens
j'avais fait des premières des premières
évaluations j'en avais dit un mot à la
ministre à l'époque mais moi je gère non
on gère 700 000 logements d'accord ça
donne quand même une ordre de grandeur
mais moi j'avais sous-estimé les
passoires thermiques parce que en
réalité une bonne partie de ce que je
gère c'est ce que j'ai produit donc j'ai
un pas je suis en gestion d'un parc qui
est sans doute beaucoup plus jeune et en
bonne bien meilleur état que le parc
normal
et je trouve que qu'on découvre
aujourd'hui que la moitié des logements
qui sont dans le marché locatif privé de
l'Île-de-France sont doivent être
rénovés c'est quand même une énorme
affaire c'est voilà
et donc tout ça n'est pas mesuré moi je
pense que vous l'avez compris je pense
que quelquefois il faut aider un peu la
main invisible de marcher parce que
quand même l'état voilà on peut dire que
garde ce rôle là de de de mesurer moi je
pense que les Français ne sont pas du
tout en résistance à ça mais parce
qu'ils veulent payer ils ont peur de la
facture d'énergie c'est moi je le vois
ils ont ils ont très bien compris ce qui
se passait vraiment ils ont bien compris
que le bouclier tarifaire ils peuvent
aller ils savent très bien l'effort que
fait l'état ils savent que ça ils ont
tout compris donc je pense qu'il faut
vraiment y aller mais il faut y aller
avec un peu de planification quand même
alors peut-être un méchant mot mais en
tout cas de réflexion et de mesure des
ordres de grandeur et bon et puis là je
crois que quand même si on met de
l'argent public il faut qu'on soit tous
raisonnable
il faut qu'on fasse avec l'argent public
des travaux qui sont quand même très
élégantes j'ai entendu des choses sur ma
prime redev la prime rénove nous c'est
ce qui nous permet de financer les
études c'est-à-dire que grosso modo
quand on dit à
une copropriété vraiment nous on pense
parce qu'on connaît très bien nos
copropriétés que si vous faisiez des
travaux
ce serait très rentable parce que
vraiment voilà bah il faut vraiment
qu'on soit en capacité derrière de
décliner ça et on voit vraiment que le
droit de la copropriété quand même
hyperprotecteur de chacun des
propriétaires nous on a des
propriétaires qui disparaissent
complètement des âgées on les voit pas
là j'ai semé d'accord et derrière le
propriétaire attaque en disant hop je ne
suis pas d'accord ils ont intérêt à agir
on est tranquille après vous êtes trois
ans tranquille non ça ne va pas on va
dire juste ça ne va pas et du coup vous
avez à l'intérieur de ces bâtiments de
des personnes qui veulent continuer à
louer leur logement enfin c'est c'est du
rendement c'est enfin quand même il y a
beaucoup de personnes enfin je pense pas
uniquement aux héritage mais
il y a quand même ça au moins un flux
qui va rentrer donc voilà
sur le logement étudiant vraiment vous
êtes la bienvenue nous nous on est
vraiment une maison très ouverte si on
peut aider les étudiants j'avais pas
cette idée que les étudiants étrangers
avaient plus de mal à se loger que les
autres on est vraiment prêt à trouver
des solutions et des
il y a toujours des solutions si on est
pragmatique et l'avantage d'une
entreprise c'est qu'elle peut être
pragmatique il y a toujours des
solutions oui pragmatique évite agile
bon sur le marché de la de la location
j'y reviens pas le fait que
des clients se présentent chez nous et
qu'on ne puisse pas leur offrir la
location d'autisme c'est vraiment un
sujet je considère que c'est vraiment un
sujet moi je suis pour vous faire
sourire je suis beaucoup les avis Google
sur mes agences c'est un premier truc je
me prends des trucs sur le truc cette
agence sexy elle est nulle j'avais j'ai
besoin d'un logement je n'en trouve pas
oui ils ont raison enfin mais mais c'est
quand même bien ce qui se passe
je pense qu'on commence quand même avoir
des alors de nouveau moi je sais pas
comment on mesure la gravité de ces
sujets mais on commence à avoir des
sujets de décohabitation des jeunes chez
nous quand même moi je suis parti de
chez moi j'avais 17 ans ça m'est paru
normal
les jeunes qui parlent à 17 ans de chez
eux en ce moment c'est
j'ai pas acheté à 17 ans je vous rassure
mais enfin il y a beaucoup de jeunes qui
qui restent chez eux on les adore et il
nous adore mais je pense qu'il y a un
moment ils ont juste envie de vivre leur
vie c'est normal enfin non mais moi je
trouve que enfin je sais pas moi il y a
des moments je me dis quand même on dit
des choses à nos jeunes quelquefois ça
me ça m'arrache le cœur Bref et la
spéculation je sais moi j'en vois pas
tant que ça de la spéculation je vois la
réponse à un besoin c'est pas un marché
spéculatif de mon point de vue c'est
vraiment un marché qui qui tente de
répondre à un besoin voilà et
franchement le besoin il tape à la porte
fort et moi je suis intéressé de savoir
j'ai pas encore les chiffres mais ce que
ce que va demander la file des
demandeurs de logement social comment ça
se passe par définition
ça va trop être aussi il y a pas de
raison
merci Henri Cabanel ensuite
Anne-Catherine Loisy et Joël Labbé
merci madame la présidente Madame la
Directrice Générale merci pour vos
propos vous avez dit que l'essentiel
retractivité se faisait le meilleur B
une grande ville moyenne donc je voulais
vous poser la question est-ce que vos
activités aussi s'élargissent dans le
ruralité enfin dans les ruralité puisque
un de nos anciens collègues lozériens de
la commission des affaires économiques
parler de l'hyperalité donc voilà est-ce
que vos activités aussi s'élargissent
dans l'hyper ruralité
et concernant donc la construction donc
de logement par rapport à la rvv est-ce
que vous utilisez donc le bois comme
matériaux dans quel proportion et
quelles en sont les freins
merci Anne-Catherine
s
j'en ai d'autres merci beaucoup madame
pour votre témoignage une approche très
terrain en fait j'ai beaucoup de petites
questions vous avez parlé de pension de
famille est-ce que vous pouvez nous
définir qu'est-ce qu'une pension de
famille puisque je voilà effectivement
vous dites à un moment que 10% de mieux
que la R20 en fait ça veut dire quoi
voilà
la part du bois donc dans dans vos
rénovations
quels sont les alternatives que vous
proposez aujourd'hui
énergétique puisque là vous avez parlé
des difficultés qu'est-ce que vous
préconisez en fait électricité pompe à
chaleur ou autre
quel est vous avez parlé de la taille
moyenne du logement quelle est la taille
moyenne du logement en France et quelle
est la taille moyenne du logement en
Europe parce que je quand on écoute les
débats aujourd'hui on se rend compte
aussi que la problématique elle est
vraiment européenne je pense à
l'Allemagne en situation apparemment est
vraiment catastrophique et puis enfin
est-ce que vous avez mesuré concrètement
en fait vous avez quantifié l'impact de
la législation Lausanne sur vos
activités ce que ça veut dire que vous
renoncez à un certain nombre de de
projets merci merci et pour finir cette
série Joël Labé oui merci madame la
présidente madame la Présidente je
voudrais vous parler de des communes
littorales et des difficultés sur les
communes électorales notamment en
Bretagne qui depuis une dizaine d'années
est victime quelque part de son
attractivité avec les grosses
difficultés sinon les impossibilités
pour les jeunes ménage de s'installer
sur le sur le littoral parce que l'accès
la propriété n'est pas possible et la
location non plus faute de faute de
logement alors qu'il y a pléthore de
résidence secondaire il s'agit pas de
rendre les résidences secondaires
à la location mais c'est quand même un
vrai sujet dans le dans la mesure où on
doit économiser le terrain
et sur certaines communes c'est 70% de
des habitations qui sont résidences
secondaires voilà je sais que les
réponses sont difficiles par rapport à
cela mais on doit regarder les choses en
face et tenter de donner des réponses
merci merci madame la Présidente
alors sur la ruralité oui nous sommes
présents dans les zones rurales on a des
filiales qui s'appellent esprit village
alors je ne vous cache pas que souvent
évidemment l'équilibre économique de
sortie souvent plus complexe mais on
travaille dessus et Florence nous sommes
même allés avec le sénateur du Tarn
c'est ça Philippe folio il m'a dit mais
pourquoi vous travaillez pas assez chez
nous et ben pour tout vous dire
mon patron du logement est allé passer
une journée avec lui dans le Tarn pour
voir où est-ce qu'on pourrait intervenir
comment et je vous assure que
mon patron est revenu tout à fait
enthousiaste et donc on va aller
intervenir dans le Tarn ou on était
peut-être pas assez présent donc moi je
suis très pragmatique en fait voilà si
il y a toujours des solutions il faut
travailler et sincèrement quand on a le
soutien des élus locaux enfin on peut
faire des miracles quelquefois non mais
c'est vrai vous le savez tous
donc pour vous dire que voilà nous on
est présent
on a besoin qu'on soit
il nous vingt mille logements évidemment
on ne ferait pas 20.000 logements
uniquement en zone métropolitaine ça
n'existe pas et nous on est présent
depuis très longtemps dans dans les
villes dites secondaires on a des
agences on est présent donc on a
l'habitude de travailler sur ces
territoires et sur la ruralité ben voilà
comme je vous dis moi j'interviens de
toute façon très pragmatique je dis pas
je suis pas là je le sénateur c'était un
déjeuner avec lui il m'interpelle en
disant mais vous travaillez pas assez
chez nous je dis bah très bien on y va
voilà et donc je vous dis mon patron
c'est le patron qui est allé voir parce
que je pense qu'il faut définir des
équilibres économiques etc ils ont passé
une journée tous les deux et il est
revenu en disant on va trouver on va
trouver des solutions on va trouver des
voilà donc
sur sur le bois on est le premier
producteur de de logement et de
tertiaire en bois dans ce pays moi je
pense qu'il faut être très pragmatique
il y a eu un moment où le bois c'était
l'alpha et l'oméga de tout et vous avez
compris que je suis un peu taquine de
temps en temps j'ai fini par dire on va
quand même pas construire partout le
Range de David crock d'abord c'est pas
possible c'est pas notre histoire et
donc et donc je pense que nous on est
très pragmatique de nouveau et c'est
comme ça qu'on a gagné le concours de la
Porte de Montreuil je pense qu'il faut
aller chercher tous les matériaux
possibles voilà
et puis il faut et moi j'ai vraiment
beaucoup retravaillé tous ces sujets là
il faut être pragmatique vous avez
compris que c'était un peu notre mot
d'ordre
tes théologique sur ces trucs là ça on
arrive à des sujets où les Français
peuvent puissent loger donc et donc on
tente de travailler beaucoup sur
qu'est-ce que le plus adapté c'est à
dire que ou le béton il existe du béton
bas carbone les boîtes elles travaillent
ou le béton est vraiment indispensable
et utile ou est le bois nous on a
retravaillé complètement nos modes
constructif on ne met dans nos
constructions que ce qui est
absolument indispensable on n'a pas par
ailleurs par exemple un produit Ewood
madame est Président on en a j'ai
vérifié à Sartrouville ou vraiment on a
complètement
travailler c'est un chantier bois c'est
un chantier merveille aujourd'hui c'est
propre comme tout c'est très rapide à
construire
et c'est très chaleureux à l'intérieur
c'est pas forcément vous voyez le bois
dire mais une sorte de chaleur du bois
bon je ne vous cache pas que nous avons
quelques soucis avec les pompiers quand
même quand les choses deviennent un peu
plus voilà
donc moi je pense toujours beaucoup de
pragmatiques
nous on tente vraiment on a on essaye la
pierre crue on est on essaie la pierre à
Porte de Montreuil on essaie même alors
il y a pas il y a pas pour l'instant
d'industrialisation mais de reconstruire
un bâtiment on a choisi une architecte
mexicaine c'est très intéressant c'est
culture différente elle nous a dit moi
je vais essayer de vous faire un
bâtiment avec au fond le ce qu'on va
travailler des débris d'un bâtiment
qu'on va détruire bon je je vous
garantis pas l'équilibré économique tout
de suite mais je pense que ça s'essaye
il faut tout essayer voilà
donc je pense beaucoup de pragmatisme le
bois oui mais pas que le bois au bon
endroit le bois utile l'avantage du bois
c'est que enfin modulo le fait que le
bois a beaucoup augmenté mais c'est des
chantiers très propres c'est des
chantiers rapides c'est du chantier en
2D on arrive avec voilà
mais il faut vraiment tout explorer il
faut pas lâcher le béton en race
campagne complètement les industriels
font vraiment beaucoup de travail autour
de ces sujets je pense qu'il faut être à
l'A de tout ce qui peut nous arriver
pension de famille pardon j'ai été un
peu rapide pension de famille ce sont
parce que vous savez tout ça mais
quelquefois je le rappelle moi je l'ai
vu à Paris
vous ne sortez pas des gens de la rue en
leur donnant la clé d'un logement ça
n'existe pas quand vous avez vécu à la
rue pendant des mois vous réflexe ne
sont plus du tout les réflexes de
quelqu'un qui vit dans un logement donc
il faut un sas gérer par des par des
associations qui savent ce qu'elles font
donc vous il faut déjà un format je l'ai
fait à Paris c'est c'est très
impressionnant ça beaucoup vous êtes
tous des élus locaux historiquement vous
les avez sans doute il y a des gens qui
c'est très dur de les sortir de la rue
c'est très très dur donc on les on les
en fait on les reçoit et moi j'en ai vu
pas mal et c'est très émouvant quand
même
par exemple beaucoup de des résidents
sont ravis vous allez vraiment rire mais
c'est très mignon
ils ont une clé leur appartement ils ont
une clé la boîte aux lettres et pour eux
il se passe rien je vous rassure d'un
pas plus que dans la vôtre ou dans la
mienne mais ces deux clés ont
bien sûr mais nous on a l'habitude vous
avez tous une clé dans votre sac ou dans
vos poches messieurs pour nous c'est
normal pour eux c'est voilà donc et nous
on est vraiment là-dedans c'est moi je
voilà je ne finance pas tellement d'art
ou de on s'est vraiment concentré sur
les pensions de famille et c'est quand
même très apprécié des marques parce que
c'est très encadré
dans les quartiers parce que c'est très
encadré c'est 20 personnes une pension
de famille vous n'êtes pas dans des
trucs moi je trouve que ça crée des
quartiers vrai avec des populations
diverses ça peut créer des zones de
solidarité aussi ça crée de l'humain
donc c'est une c'est vraiment quelque
chose auquel on tient beaucoup et
vraiment je moi quand je parle de ça
Omer ils sont très enfin franchement
quel que soit la couleur politique
historique ça n'a rien à voir avec rien
c'est vraiment à condition que
évidemment je travaille avec eux ce qui
enfin vous imaginez bien que je demande
pas le permis pour une pension de sa
famille sans avoir tout préparé avec les
mères donc c'est souvent l'endroit le
moment mais franchement je suis à 90%
extrêmement bien accueilli sur ces
sujets là
si vous avez envie d'en visiter
d'ailleurs Florence me dit beaucoup de
mes clients demandent à le voir si vous
êtes toujours bienvenus chez nous moi je
pense qu'on est une maison ouverte s'il
y a des choses que vous avez envie de
voir vraiment où vous emmène partout on
a des équipes partout je dis 60 patrons
ils seront absolument ravis si vous avez
des curiosités ou des demandes vraiment
on est à l'écoute Florence a raison 10%
de mieux de la que l'aéron c'est qu'on
va 10% plus vite
c'est à dire que je fais un peu je fais
un peu plus de re 20 20 niveau 2025
maintenant que je ne le devrais voilà
c'est ça que ça dit je vais plus vite
sur l'énergie c'est un sujet central la
r2020 nous pousse quand même bien
gentiment vers les pompes à chaleur
quand même je vous le dis voilà
donc là moi ce que j'ai travaillé sur
les bombes à chaleur c'est des marchés
globaux pour être sûr qu'il y a de la
Pro hein parce que c'est pareil tout à
coup tout le monde a besoin de pompe à
chaleur voilà et puis on a vraiment de
nouveau nous on travaille beaucoup la
technique moi que j'ai besoin quand les
équipes locales montent les pompes à
chaleur elle sache exactement quel film
mettre ou est-ce qu'on les met comment
ça s'installe donc ça on l'a on l'a
travaillé et autant que alors il y a des
solutions il y a d'autres solutions il y
a la géothermie etc mais c'est vrai que
la Revan 20 a quand même beaucoup
beaucoup poussé sur les pompes à chaleur
et peut-être ça fait partie des choses
qu'on pourra dans le temps assouplir
parce qu'il y a d'autres solutions il
faut pas se concentrer moi pour
l'instant je voilà je suis sur la mais
je pense que et puis je pense qu'il y a
encore des choses à trouver en matière
d'énergie j'ai besoin de choses beaucoup
plus décentralisées des choses beaucoup
plus voilà donc là sur l'énergie on est
vraiment à l'écoute à la recherche
d'idées de et il y en aura forcément et
nous on est à la recherche de solution
vraiment plus simple qui pourrait
s'adapter parce que vous vous souvenez
qu'une partie de mon métier sur
l'existant moi aujourd'hui quand on
proposait solutions je dis d'accord mais
ce que tu me proposes là est-ce que ça
va sur le nœud c'est super est-ce que si
je renomme un bâtiment ancien est-ce que
je peux faire la même chose alors
souvent il y a un moment d'hésitation il
retourne ils reviennent mais vraiment
c'est ça aussi qu'il faut qu'on imagine
parce que quelquefois être en capacité
de mettre une pompe à chaleur sur un
bâtiment existant ce qui doit être si
simple ben ça ça vous produit quand même
beaucoup de beaucoup d'économies
d'énergie et de rénovation
vous m'avez demandé également sur les
ânes je pense que
en réalité même avant même avant l'idée
de lasagne moi ce que je vois parce que
je marche beaucoup vous l'avez compris
il y a eu quand même nous on a fait ce
qu'on appelait des lotissements j'ai je
déteste ce mot que je trouve hyper moche
mais on construisait pas mais on
aménageait on est des aménageurs on n'a
jamais on fait pas de maison
individuellement on aménageait moi ce
que je constate c'est quand même par
rapport à il y a 10 ans
ces zones là sont beaucoup plus denses
on a quand même des maisons plus hautes
franchement elles sont les unes à côté
des autres et les terrains sont beaucoup
plus petits donc je pense que cette idée
d'économiser le foncier il est quand
même rentré dans voilà et vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure moi je pense qu'on
peut pas enfin je sais pas comment on
peut interdire complètement aux Français
s'il le souhaitent d'avoir il faut qu'on
soit tous raisonnable il faut qu'on soit
raisonnable mais moi enfin je sais pas
mais je et de nouveau je pense qu'on
commence à produire plus de collectif
que de maisons individuelles mais voilà
il y a des il y a des Français qui ont
envie d'une maison individuelle ils ont
le droit d'avoir une maison individuelle
il faut juste que collectivement soit
raisonnable sur la consommation de
foncier que ça entraîne
et sur les résidences secondaires nous
on en fait on en fait assez peu mais
vous avez raison j'ai vu un projet
récemment en Bretagne c'était près de
Lorient et c'est la première fois que je
voyais un dossier comme ça chez Nexity
on m'a dit j'ai dit mais qui achète ils
m'ont dit la véronique c'est
je sais plus quelle est la vie ouais je
crois et et vraiment il y a une très
grosse appétence pour les résidences
secondaires chez vous alors après moi je
sais pas c'est je pense que ça c'est
vraiment des c'est vraiment des comment
dirais des politiques locales et
nationales qu'est-ce qu'on fait des
résidences secondaires enfin honnêtement
je pense que aujourd'hui les résidents
secondaires les propriétaires sont quand
même entre la taxe d'habitation
lithi etc sont comment sont quand même
être incitées à
rentabiliser vous avez raison ça ne si
vous avez une résidence secondaire vous
pouvez pas la louer à l'année ou parce
que après vous n'en profitez plus donc
je pense que les résidents secondaires
sont un sujet qu'on est en mais qui
dépasse un peu mes compétences de
promoteur
très bien je on va prendre de toutes les
dernières questions parce qu'il y a
encore quelques intervenants et le temps
tourne donc je vais donner la parole à
Sylviane Noël puis à Micheline Jack
merci madame la présidente madame la
Présidente général il ne me semble pas
vous avoir entendu parler du projet que
vous menez actuellement à Lyon
expérimental et très novateur visant à
la construction d'un immeuble sans
chauffage ni climatisation si à part
dans j'ai raté excusez-moi je passe à la
question désolé
du coup c'est bon ah bah du coup c'est
bon voilà merci Sylviane Micheline Jack
qui va sûrement nous emmener en
outre-mer
merci Madame le présidente madame la
Présidente
dans mes recherches je n'ai pas trouvé
de programme outre-mer donc on
disposez-vous et dans la négative
pourriez-vous nous expliquer les raisons
pour lesquelles vous n'investissez pas
en outre-mer
très bien Patricia Sillinger à laquelle
je souhaite un bon anniversaire voilà
merci merci
[Rires]
Madame la Directrice
dans votre parc je souhaitais vous poser
la question est-ce que vous avez les les
nouvelles résidences qui sont mixtes
maintenant que je vois aussi développer
dans mon département le rez-de-chaussée
dédié à la location des personnes âgées
des veuves qui se retrouvent seuls et
qui n'ont plus les moyens ni et veuf et
je dois dire dans la commune où je vis
de 2800 habitants ça fonctionne très
bien et ça pousse comme des petits pains
le rez-de-chaussée reste locatif social
parce que dans d'autres résidences c'est
plutôt 2000 euros là non non c'est des
loyers qui sont gérés et ça marche très
bien et je voulais savoir si vous avez
dans vos projets dans d'autres
départements cette explosion de de
demande et c'est vraiment cette
cohabitation marche super bien avec
d'autres habitants et donc peut-être le
futur nous amène vraiment à des
solutions qui sont aussi pour les aînés
et pas que pour les jeunes merci
Patricia j'espère que c'est pas ton
anniversaire qui te fait réfléchir à ça
merci je vais revenir rapidement sur le
sujet de la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments une au ciné une commission
d'enquête sur l'efficacité de ces
politiques publiques menées depuis
quelques temps va être va démarrer fin
du mois j'avais une question plutôt
assez précise puisque dans un de ces
derniers rapports la Cour des comptes
évoquait le dispositif ma prime rénov et
le fait que seul 2500 logements
sortaient en tout cas de de cette
qualification de passeport énergétique
ce qui paraît peu suffisant et ma
question est simple selon vous quelles
sont les orientations pour
aujourd'hui accélérer la rénovation
thermique des habitants et puis autre
sujet dans certaines de vos
interventions vous pas j'aime beaucoup
cette idée là vous passez vous parler
pardon d'un ministère de la ville de
demain donc passer en fait du ministère
de
du logement c'est ça la ville de demain
avec et c'est ça que je trouve
intéressant finalement toutes les
questions clés qui se posent sur comment
vivre dans la ville de demain comment
nous allons loger nos enfants demain et
je voulais en savoir un petit peu plus
en tout cas sur ce sujet là merci merci
Amel et pour finir Anne chalarcher oui
madame la président directrice générale
j'ai juste une question qui est tout à
fait liée au monde rural il y a beaucoup
de communes qui doivent construire des
gendarmerie aujourd'hui est-ce que il
arrive que Nexity soit associé à ce type
de projet
du logement de gendarme en fonction
madame la Présidente
c'est quand même un donneur d'ordre
public c'est vraiment un équipement
public quand même mais je crois de
mémoire qu'un appel d'offres qui est en
train de d'être travailler par le
ministère de l'Intérieur sur ces sujets
là et s'il y avait objet à y aller
évidemment on irait parce que c'est un
c'est un sujet logement donc mais moi je
ne me souviens pas
que nous ayons oui c'est une commande
publique enfin c'est c'est une commande
publique mais très souvent des
partenariats publics privés donc je
voulais vous sensibiliser à ça mais
c'est pour ça que je vous réponds je
pense que on a on a regardé et je crois
enfin je dis peut-être une bêtise mais
je crois qu'il y a en tout cas il y a
une initiative en cours dont j'ai
entendu parler je sais pas si toi dans
sur le sur les gendarmerie et surtout
les logements des gendarmes qui sera un
marché j'en connais pas les contours
lancé par le ministère de l'Intérieur
pour
évidemment nous comme on est partout sur
le territoire on serait vraiment enfin
pour le coup pour nous c'est
sur l'outre-mer je j'avoue à ma grande
honte que nous n'y sommes pas du tout
et je ne sais pas pourquoi parce que
cette historique je pense
pourtant mon numéro de Nexity
guadeloupéen donc c'est quand même il
devrait voilà sensible y être sensible
mais je voilà je pense que c'est un
héritage
on s'est déployé sur le territoire et
pas dans les territoires et départements
d'outre-mer et je serais incapable de
vous dire historiquement pourquoi
pardon
le risque supplémentaire non mais je
pense qu'en fait on est une entreprise
qui qui était très pragmatique en
réalité et donc on s'est déployé parce
qu'il y avait des patrons c'est souvent
comme ça que ça se passe chez nous
quelqu'un qui dit bah moi j'aimerais
bien j'aimerais bien je crois quoi
déployer le territoire de de quel
territoire et on l'intègre dans
l'entreprise et c'est comme ça qu'on a
grandi en fait c'est c'est vraiment des
rencontres et peut-être que jamais
personne n'est venu me voir en disant
bah voilà
je connais très bien la Réunion
n'importe quoi la réunion
je pense qu'il y a de la demande je
connais ce qu'il faut moi je je ne sais
pas faire à chaque fois qu'on l'a fait
ça c'est pas bien passé
le marché du logement est un marché je
vais enfoncé de nouveau une porte
ouverte en courant mais extrêmement
local il faut vraiment comprendre plein
de choses de par exemple de
l'architecture moi je maintenant je
commence je suis assez fine pour
reconnaître un projet du nord de Lyon ou
du Sud c'est pas les mêmes en fait il
faut que bien connaître il faut bien
connaître le nous on travaille beaucoup
avec des entreprises locales et on livre
parce qu'on connaît très bien ces
entreprises locales parce que
nos patrons c'est des gens qui sont qui
ont grandi mon patron de Marseille il a
grandi à Marseille il connaît
l'environnement il a construit des
relations de confiance et moi je sais
pas me on l'a tenté c'est pas bien on et
même à l'étranger ça ne marche pas on se
projetant en disant tient un claque j'y
vais et donc moi j'ai besoin de de
vraiment d'enracinement local de volonté
locale d'un patron qui me convainc que
il peut y aller et hop on y va on est
vraiment je vous l'ai dit on est une
petite grosse boîte et on est vraiment
extrêmement pragmatique sur ces sujets
là résidence interne régionale et vous
avez raison ça marche du tonnerre de
Dieu notre expérience c'est qu'il faut
quand même que ce soit géré il faut il
faut quand même qu'il y ait une
animation parce que sinon vous savez
malheureusement le monde dans lequel on
est on peut se retrouver avec des gens
qu'on a choisi il faut le gérer dans le
temps aussi
et puis les gens sont timides on a perdu
l'habitude de au fond d'interagir avec
nos voisins on a peur de les gêner les
donc il faut vraiment de l'animation ça
marchera très bien quand je suis allé au
Havre par exemple on a une résidence
interne intergénérationnelle il y a une
pièce en bas et or c'est très
intéressant parce que tout le monde
passe je vais faire mes courses je passe
une tête on ne sait jamais c'est marrant
comme tout mais ça crée et pour les
personnes âgées c'est vraiment sympa ça
il y a des jeunes aussi enfin je parle
personne âgées mais voilà il y a des
jeunes qui dessinaient parce que voilà
maman venait faire je sais pas quoi du
coup il se mettait mais du coup nous on
aime beaucoup les maires nous les
demandent mais moi de nouveau je n'y
vais pas sans je n'y vais pas sans
animation faut que ça fonctionne dans la
durée je crois que au Havre ça va être
les maisons de Marianne de mémoire
on peut faire des miracles dès qu'on est
soutenu par une collectivité qui a un
projet on peut enfin en vrai on peut
faire des miracles
à quoi je n'ai-je pas répondu à tout non
j'ai une question que j'ai oublié
ma prime rénove ma prime rénove m'a
prime rénov pardonnez-moi oui ma prime
rénove moi je lui dis tout à l'heure
c'est quand même très utile parce que ça
ça lance le dispositif c'est à dire que
moi je peux dire aux copropriétaire moi
je pense qu'il faut qu'on garde je pense
qu'il y a des améliorations possibles et
la prime rénov permet de financer les
premières études donc je sais que
l'étude va être remboursée donc c'est ça
ça c'est bête mais ça facilite quand
même l'entrée dans le dispositif et
après le problème de la prime rénove
c'est que comme le droit des
copropriétés très compliqué vous
finissez par faire et c'est ce que dit
la cour c'est pas toujours efficace vous
finissez par faire des travaux dans un
seul logement ce qui est le pire parce
que franchement ça va vous coûter très
cher pour monter alors que une
rénovation globale peut être beaucoup
plus efficace c'est juste que la
rénovation globale
vous êtes propriétaires bailleurs vous
pouvez plus vous savez que dans deux ans
vous pouvez plus louer les autres
veulent pas faire de travaux vous faites
quoi vous vendez vous donc vous êtes
vous faites les petits travaux et ça
c'est ça c'est cher inefficace c'est ça
c'est le sujet dans lequel on rentre
c'est que si on veut faire de la
rénovation efficace et être raisonnable
avec l'argent public qui doit être
efficace c'est de l'argent public quand
même et ben il faut quand même pousser
les copropriété
très bien merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Directrice générale
merci infiniment de ces réponses je
pense qu'on aura sûrement l'occasion de
se recroiser pendant les mois qui
viennent soit sur des missions
d'information soit sur des commissions
d'enquêtes soi-même dans le cadre des
travaux de la commission qui ne
manqueront pas de concerner le logement
merci infiniment de votre écoute je ne
peux pas dire mieux si voilà si on peut
aider si vous avez des questions si vous
avez envie de voir des choses ma maison
est ouverte je pense que voilà vous avez
une grande maison
merci beaucoup
c'est beaucoup de grandes et petites
maisons oui c'est vrai mais moi je
possède rien je suis pas une foncière
j'ai rien en propre je gère et